malgré la chute brutale des derniers
jours rappelons nous que les marchés ont
connu une hausse spectaculaire au cours
des dernières années
pendant la crise financière le s&p 500 a
touché un creux de 676 points c'était le
9 mars 2009
depuis lundi ça grimpé de plus de 400%
depuis dix ans il y a eu six correction
boursière dont deux en 2018
les marchés ont toujours réussi à
récupérer le terrain perdu mais parfois
à seulement plusieurs mois plus tard
analyse explication ce soir georges du
jeu et pdg de galileo advisor à new york
bonsoir monsieur je bonjour monsieur
fillon alors quelle analyse vous faites
de ce qu'on vit présentement je crois
que il y avait beaucoup d' indices
depuis des mois qui s'accumulaient
autour des problèmes boursiers et de
l'économie on voyait on sentait bien que
l'économie était sous tension que la
croissance n'était pas au rendez vous
que les déficits budgétaires explosent
et malgré ça ou le street a continué à
monter
je pense que ce à quoi nous assistons
c'est que le coronavirus a été plus un
catalyste est révélateur et il a comme
fait je dirais lépingle qui a fait
exploser le ballon parce que nous
sortons d'une très grosse bulle et nous
allons progressivement perdre tout ce
que nous avons gagné depuis 18 mois nous
avons déjà en tout cas très sérieusement
commencé elles ce sont les problèmes
fondamentaux maintenant qu'ils sont au
rendez vous et là ce moment-là nous
puisque nous trouver sur une situation
beaucoup plus longues et donc vous vous
attendez à ce que cette correction
boursière se poursuive
elles pourraient se poursuivre elle va
certainement avoir des agitations dans
un sens ou dans l'autre ce le dow jones
a monté de 500 points dans le dernier
quart d'heure il ya de la manipulation
dans l'air chacun essaye de faire ce
qu'il veut mais la réalité est qu'il
faut bien comprendre que le corps un
avis rue ça a été une occasion et que ce
n'est pas lui qui peut provoquer des
chutes de 6000 milliards de dollars de
valeur boursière il y a des éléments
fondamentaux qui pour le moment sont
occupés à menacer temps l'économie
américaine que l'économie mondiale
quelles sont ces éléments fondamentaux
selon vous
alors il ya évidemment le problème de
l'endettement nous avons connu une une
croissance dans la triple et
l'endettement des états dans le monde
occidental il y a évidemment le problème
des états unis où on sent que la
croissance qui était à 3% va défendre en
dessous de 2%
on sent aussi que le déficit budgétaire
n'est pas une préoccupation du président
des états unis et nous sommes dans une
période électorale passablement agités
donc je dirais que c'est simplement si
on prend le continent nord américain
je dirais que de ce côté là le canada
devrait être un pays de refus est-ce
qu'on a oui vous croyez dans quel sens
absolument je crois que la situation
économique du canada est beaucoup plus
solide
la situation politique est plus stable
la gestion des finances publiques est
meilleure et vous avez déjà une bonne
partie de vos problèmes de retraite qui
ont été résolus fait beaucoup de choses
que d'autres pays n'ont pas réussi à
faire en même temps le canada est quand
même bien exposée au commerce
international la chute du prix du
pétrole également le ralentissement du
tourisme
c'est certainement un sujet c'est à dire
que si on devait entrer dans une grave
récession en ce moment là les prix du
pétrole suivrait mais pour le moment en
terme de finances globales
le canada a poursuivi une politique
beaucoup plus conservatrice est à mon
avis plus solide
alors revenons au marché est ce que vous
croyez qu'on assiste à la fin du marché
aussi le bull market
non le bull market n'a pas encore tout à
fait terminée je dirais que moi je vois
beaucoup plus les marchés de l'ordre de
20 milles plus tout venant de 26 27
mille donc c'est une correction beaucoup
plus forte
mais ça peut se faire en douceur la
question que j'ai pour le moment il ya
laquelle personne n'a de réponse
est-ce qu'on va lundi se relancer à la
hausse
ou bien est ce que véritablement les
marchés ont commencé à prendre
conscience des problèmes structurels
auxquels n'ont pas attacher une
importance dans les dernières années
si si dans les prochains jours
la situation est davantage contenu sur
la question du coronavirus parce que
c'est de cela dont il est question on
croyait
en début février que la situation était
contenue davantage à la chine et que les
répercussions internationales allaient
plutôt être faible et là on a vraiment
changé de perspectives compte tenu du
nombre de cas qui se sont additionnés
dans plusieurs pays même si on n'a pas
une tonne il ya quand même eu un
questionnement sur l'impact du
coronavirus si les nouvelles sont
meilleures est ce que vous croyez que
l'embellie boursière va se poursuivre
reprendre en quelque sorte je crois
qu'on est avec le coronavirus pour
longtemps parce que c'est une maintenu
une maladie extrêmement difficile à
suivre c'est une espèce de fièvre
prirent pernicieuse 7 qui atteint les
poumons et qui donc pu donner les pubs
des pneumonies
mais il atteint essentiellement une
partie de la population qui est plus
fragile je ne vois pas des millions de
victimes du coronavirus par contre sur
le plan de l'impact économique une des
questions que je me pose c'est pourquoi
prends ton des mesures aussi drastiques
pour un problème qui est tout compte
fait pas terriblement important au point
que finalement la réaction coronavirus
pour récréer à elle seule un
ralentissement supplémentaire de
l'économie qui pourrait mettre
l'économie en récession
ben écoute l oms a quand même parlé d'un
risque très élevé aujourd'hui le taux de
mortalité est quand même beaucoup plus
important que la grève que la grippe
normale donc le danger le danger il
existe même si le risque demeure faible
cela dit est ce que vous pensez qu'une
intervention des pouvoirs publics sera
nécessaire je pense quand je dis
pouvoirs publics à la fois la réserve
fédérale qui baisse des taux ou le
gouvernement fédéral qui investit
davantage dans l'économie pour stimuler
l'économie
dans la situation actuelle je crois
qu'il est beaucoup trop tôt pour parler
d'intervention je crois que ce qu'a dit
gerry powell à propos de la situation de
la federal reserve est tout à fait sensé
à mon avis si vous baissez les taux ça
ne change absolument rien non pourquoi
parce que nous sommes devant des
questions parce que nous sommes ce sont
des questionnements sur le problème de
la santé sur le problème de l'économie
et je ne crois pas aujourd'hui que si
comme vous l'avez dit vous-même les taux
qui sont déjà extrêmement bas sont un
tout petit peu plus bas
la machine va se remettre en route
est-ce que ça ouvre ce lundi la porte à
des occasions d'achat d'un strict
le point de vue d'investisseur qui
regarde ça est-ce que tout à coup vous
comme investisseur vous voyez des
occasions d'achat alors pour tout vous
avouer je suis depuis deux ans
complètement en cache donc je n'ai pas
investi et au niveau où nous sommes pour
le moment j'en ai pris pour 10%
donc je suis encore très prudent mais
c'est une occasion d'achat par contre
pour ceux qui sont déjà exposées au
marché des actions
c'est trop tard pour ordre il faut
certainement pas en reprendre très vite
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur jeu
pour cet entretien ce soir ils se
regardent au revoir avec avec paisible
se fiant au revoir